good morning believe nation today's
message is work on your calling / - you
can do Reeves I left home when I was 17
18 I drove from Toronto Canada to Los
Angeles when I was 20 and moved out of
my home when I was 18 so the beginning
had you know I could take care of myself
as a teenager when I moved to the states
I had some family and I had a lot of
rejection uh but uh know who did you
want to be I mean how how do you how did
you foresee your future as an actor I
didn't I was just wanted to do it you
know I I was very self-motivated when I
was in school I was taking acting
classes at night I was going to summer
stock theater I was doing community
theater um you know I was just you were
simply enjoying it I was enjoying it but
I visit kind of I don't want to use the
word calling you know but I'm destiny I
don't know if it was destiny it's just
what I wanted to do hey you know but and
still you know hopefully it's doing
doing it yeah so enjoying it and still
working and working I call it I think
the interesting thing about colleen's
are are that you nothing don't know it
often doesn't have a lot of certainty
you can feel drawn to something but
you're always unsure of that's the thing
that you should be doing or not and I
think the lack of certainty prevents
people from getting started I think
people have curiosities and interesting
things but they don't know how it's
gonna work out they don't know how
they're gonna make money from it they
don't know how they gonna be successful
with it and so it's just a lot safer and
easier to do what you already know or
what you went to school for even though
you don't really have an interest in it
you want to go off and do something else
and I think what really helps at least
for me is to not make it this huge
important thing that I have to have it
all figured out to not make the stakes
so hard that this has to be
thing that works out because when you do
that it's such a big obstacle to
overcome that you really get started
where I like to chase curiosity I like
to explore I like to try new things if I
get a new idea I'll just try it and not
attach all sorts of you know this this
must work to it that would prevent me
from from getting started I think having
that mentality that it's okay to try
things and to fail it's okay to explore
without knowing how it's gonna work out
eases the burden eases a stress and I
think helps you find your call and I
think if you look at the people who have
found their calling at the start they
may not have had a clear plan but they
just kept following their intuition they
kept following their curiosity and they
led to something that was massively
successful you don't get there by
playing it safe and by being afraid to
try something new and doing something
just because that's what you went to
school for so the question today today
is how did you find your calling or what
is your calling leaving the in the
comments below I'm going to join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events Press